I don't know what to say I'm speechless
you would you would believe that that's
a that a predator is a prophet who uses
God as his
CRS
[Music]
God what about his moral character do
you think that have you heard about his
marriage with Aisha yeah I have and
you're okay with
that so apparently Prophet Muhammad
married a well I guess it doesn't say
this in the Quran so I don't even know
how this is where is it coming from
Hadith it comes from the Hadith which is
how you know which is how you know
anything about Islam or anything about
Muhammad at all here it is let me show
you all right so this is sah bukari so
sah bukari just to let you know it's a
it's a book of Hadith bukari is his name
the guy who collected the Hadith right
sahi means authentic this is their
second most authoritative book next to
the Quran in Sunni Islam specifically so
what does it say narrated Aisha that the
prophet married her when she was 6 years
old and he cons
his marriage when she was 9 years old
and then she remained with him for 9
years what does consummated mean it
means to have sex so the prophet married
her when she was six and slept with her
when she was nine when she was nine
years old and all of them say the same
thing the only difference that you might
see is whether she was six or seven when
he married her there's a couple that say
she was seven but all of them say are
consistent that she was 9 years old when
he slept with her we're just going to
skim through you're going to see the
same thing 6 years old 9 years old
here's another one same thing same adith
6 years old when he married her 9 years
old when he you know did the thing all
right here here's another clear one
narrated Aisha this is what I was
telling you about six or seven the
messenger of Allah married me when I was
six when I was 7 years old the narrator
sullan said or six he had intercourse
with me when I was 9 years old let me
show you that she had her dolls with her
she was playing with dolls still just in
case someone tries to say oh she was
mature oh she was growing Aisha reported
that Allah's Apostle married her when
she was 7 years old and and she was
taken to his house as a bride when she
was nine and her dolls were with her she
used to play with dolls still and when
he died she was 18 years old so are you
are you so you said you heard about this
this is what all the Hadith say are you
okay with this is my question well for
the sake of the conversation I'll assume
that they're talking about the same
years that we're talking about so yes
I don't know I mean when was this when
was this recorded like 1,500 years ago
1400 years ago 1,400 years ago okay so
it was the same years she was a little
girl or at least the six and
nine-year-old girls that I see today are
children very tiny
yeah yeah that seems weird and I've it's
not the first time I've heard this I've
always thought that was weird yeah
I I did I Ponder this a lot like well
when does a woman when when has God
turned a girl from a woman a girl to a
woman like when is she able
to children well there are signs of
maturity um when she begins to reach
puberty now that's the beginning stages
of her maturing right when she hits
puberty that's the signs that she is now
beginning to grow and mature her body
grows her you know her body develops her
mind develops she becomes a young woman
you know and is is able to Bear a child
now everybody's different with the level
or rate that they develop however got to
be got to grow and mature so God God has
made I mean I didn't make the rules
neither did you God made God made it so
that a woman can get pregnant after she
hits puberty which is defined as when
she minres for the first time not really
I mean like men menstration is not a
sign that she's ready for sex just cuz
she ministres now it's possible that she
can get pregnant ready for doesn't but
that's the purpose of sex is for a child
so if she's able to have a child then
God has made it to where if she's able
to have a child and she wants to then
she can have a child no that's not the
case it's not how that works Grayson
getting your menstrual cycle doesn't
mean that you're ready for a child like
your body's not grown yet your body's
not fully developed yet this is why but
you can get but if you can get pregnant
then so are so let me let me just ask
you this do you think that it's okay to
sleep with a with a child let me just
ask you straight up I'm not I don't plan
on it I don't I know I'm glad you don't
plan on it I didn't ask that is it
okay well what's a child is it okay I
mean if you say if you're asking me the
country I live in no you'll get you'll
get in trouble for that and ask about
the country you live in is it is it okay
to sleep with a child Grayson see if you
wasn't sucked in in in Islam you would
be able to easily answer this question
but because you're sucked in Islam well
no not with a child only should only
sleep with a woman okay so do you
believe that a prophet of God would
sleep with a little sleep with a little
girl sleep with a
child but what defines a little girl if
she's able to get pregnant let's say a
six-year-old my BR is is there is there
any world where a six-year-old or a
nine-year-old is a grown
woman I don't know any six or niney old
that can get pregnant so with what I've
seen no okay so so do you think a
prophet have God was sleep with a six or
9-year-old a six or 9-year-old girl who
cannot get
pregnant no I didn't ask that let's say
she can get pregnant let's say it's
possible that she's bled before let's
say she's bled at 6 is it okay to sleep
with her at 6 years old since she
bled I'm not I didn't ask if you're not
I ask is it okay
for someone else to do this
anyone I've been taught that that's
wrong so I would say don't do that no
you say don't do that that's what I've
been taught Muhammad did
it so would you what what defines no
excuses Grayson no excuses would you be
able to condemn Muhammad for sleeping
with a little
girl if she was a little girl yes do you
think a six-year-old or a 9-year-old is
a little girl the six or nine-year olds
that I see today yes they are little
girls okay so Muhammad slept with a
nine-year-old he slept with a little
girl will you condemn Muhammad for doing
that if Muhammad slept with a little
girl then yes according to the sources
he did according to Islam that's who
that's who you're they're trying to tell
you to follow someone who slept with a
little girl and said that God showed her
showed her to him in a dream you're
using God as an excuse for him to be
able to do
this it sounds familiar actually it
sounds like that's actually what a lot
of pedophiles say we're going to jail
their excuse a lot of their excuse we're
in love or God told me you
know yeah
I I think if you slept with a little
girl I've always thought of course I
mean I say of course but that's what
we're taught you know how old Muhammad
was no he was
4 yeah that's
weird yes it is weird that's pretty
weird yep what if the Quran taught that
this was
permissible what to sleep with a to
sleep with little girls girls before
they hit puberty what if the Quran
taught that this was okay that you can
marry them divorce them sleep with them
well the whole point of sex is to have a
child so if the Quran says that it's
okay to sleep with a girl before she can
even get pregnant I don't
I don't see why that seems pointless is
it wrong is it wrong to sleep with a
girl before puberty yes is it wrong to
sleep with a little girl
period what is a if a little girl has
hit puberty hasn't she become a woman no
she hasn't so when when does uh when
does someone go from you have any
sisters yes how does your sister I don't
want to talk about my sister's age but I
have I have two sisters okay are they
young or older both all right let's talk
about the younger one what would you say
if uh a 50y a 50-year-old man came to
her and uh tried to you know take her
hand in marriage
yeah well if I was talking to her I'd be
like why in the world do you want to be
with this guy she was like I if she
wanted to I would be like what what
would you think of the what would you
think of the guy who's trying to
approach her your little sister I would
think that he's weird that he should go
for someone more similar to his age
would you think think that he should be
in jail and that he's a predator if I
would do everything in my ability to not
let them be together let's say she was
younger than what she is now I don't
know how old she is let's say she was in
elementary I don't know if she is or not
but let's just say hypothetically and a
50-year-old man came and tried to spit
game at your sister and try to get her
hand in marriage yeah no it's it's not
even funny it'd be weird I wouldn't I'd
be like well I just be like why why like
there's so many other people would you
break his teeth if he was forcibly I
mean I guess I would first leave it up
to my father because I'm not yeah
let's what would daddy Grayson do Pap
would Papa break his teeth yeah I
wouldn't let it happen yeah he'll break
his teeth in cave his chest in right and
probably report I mean I got to say I
don't if if my daughter has reached the
age of well I guess I don't know when
she's an adult if she's like out of the
house I I would to a certain extent let
her do what she wants but I would not
want that to happen now she was under if
I was funding her life and I was
providing for her I would be like well
if you want this you can leave but I
don't want to provide for you anymore if
you want to do this so now you're going
to go and become a woman would you think
that he's would you think he's a
predator for going after a little girl
in in elementary at the age of 50 yeah
that's what Muhammad
did Muhammad Muhammad's a predator
right
yes I don't know what to say I'm
speechless and to
you would you would believe that that's
that a predator is a prophet of God who
uses God as his
CRS well where does it say I guess like
the first time I read the Quran and been
studying it since I've
never vers verses about this sure sure
let me show look I mean the first time I
read the Quran like I'm not thinking oh
I should go to sleep with a little girl
I'm thinking oh oh God is real I should
fear
God so now if it does say it in here
this is something that I
already have and will continue to take
in information to continue to process
what exactly this means oh but it's
definitely not of my first it's a
concern now I was basically an atheist
so when I understood like oh God is real
Christian atheist now embracing Islam
like oh God is real there is one God and
I'm praying to God like nowhere in my
mind unless people bring up points like
you just did like this would never be in
my thought process of after reading the
Quran so if this not saying it's not in
there but yeah if this was in the Quran
would you still consider it as maybe the
word of God if it was permitting child
abuse you think that there's a chance
that it's still the word of God if it's
teaching child abuse I mean I don't
necessarily believe that a book is from
God or not from God like the same thing
with the Bible like I don't I don't
think that oh my gosh okay all this is
just Boop let's just throw it out now
there are verses that I don't understand
and I'm not going to I think it'd be
dishonest for me to say this is the word
of God every single word in this book
and then every single word in this book
is is not so I would take that verse and
be like what in the world is this saying
I don't know what verse you're referring
to but the main message of the
Quran believe has been sent from God
that there's only one God right so it's
saying that this is the this is the the
theme bro and I I think you know this by
now that God spoke through Gabriel to
Muhammad and Muhammad is reciting the
words of God these are God's words
that's what that's what the narrative is
these are God's words so if Muhammad is
saying that God's words are that it is
permissible to sleep with marry sleep
with and divorc little girls would you
affirm that that is the word of God or
would you be able to say no that's not
from God that's a lie God would never
say something like that I don't think
the Quran says to sleep with little
girls I know what if it did that's what
I'm asking you if it said that if it
taught that would you be able to sleep
with girls before they've had puberty
yes if it taught this would you be able
to say yeah this is not from God because
the Quran claims to be the literal words
of God so it's either the words of God
say that I didn't know it said that oh
that's that's that's the claim of of
That's The thema Narrative of Islam No
they no word in the Quran is is not
Allah's word everything is Allah
speaking that's what they say yeah I
think if the Quran says you should have
you're able to it's permissible to have
sexual relation ation with a girl I know
it say it's word for word but if it said
the concept of you should have you it's
permissible to have sexual relations
with a girl before puberty I don't I
don't there's no point to that would you
be able to identify it as as a as not
the word of God that's my question if
he's saying something that is false if
he's saying something that is if he
actually said that and it's correctly
written down in the book then that would
mean he's a liar correct which would
mean he's a false prophet right
if he lied if he's saying yes if he lied
yeah okay I mean if he says that God
said it's okay to do this to sleep have
M relations with little girls marry
divorce them sleep with them if he
taught that God said this that this was
permissible would he be lying or would
he be telling the truth he would be
lying there's no there's no point the
whole point of sleeping is to have a
child so if the if the girl can't get
impregnant then it's completely for your
pleasure which is against the entire
against Christianity and Islam that
don't do things for your pleasure all
right so here's the verse here it's
chapter 65:4 as for your women who have
despaired of further as for your woman
who have Des spared a further minrating
if you are in doubt their period shall
be three months and those who have not
minated as yet in those who are with
child their term is when they they bring
forth their burden who so fears God God
will point for him of his command
easiness okay I don't understand what I
so this is what's happening so this the
chapter is called divorce right okay so
it's telling you what to do with the
females when you divorce them what's the
ruling okay so right here it's it gives
you three categories of females it gives
you the first category it gives you are
are women who are too old to ministrate
right so it says as of your women who
have despaired further ministration
meaning they're too old to further
menray all right they're in menopause so
what happens when you divorce this type
of woman if you are in doubt in doubt
about what it's talking about her being
pregnant okay all if you in doubt about
her being pregnant or whatever then
their period shall be three months right
so this is they they should wait three
months before being able to move on to
the next man okay to make sure she's not
pregnant you know okay so wait let me
make sure I'm understanding so as if a
as for a woman who has been too old
they're past the stage uh-huh they're no
longer men trting
yep if you are in doubt meaning if they
are pregnant if you doubt or if you if
they might if you think that they might
be pregnant M okay and that's where we
are yep that's where we are they're
period like you should wait three months
yeah to make sure she's not pregnant got
it all right all right boom yeah first
time I read that I did not understand
any of this yeah it's all good we got to
take these things slow uh it's a little
it's worded weird too so it's not that
all that clear then It also says here
and those um and those who have not
minated yet so the females that you're
divorcing who have not minated yet their
waiting period is 3 months as as well
you've you've slept with these girls
they haven't minated yet but you fear
that she could possibly still get
pregnant anyway three months is the is
the monthly cycle I guess H it's still
weird but how how do you know that
they've slept with them yet or they have
they just married just like very good
very good question let me show you so
notice how they have a waiting period
right they have a period of three months
all right when they're being divorced
how do we know that the men have slept
with these with these
females this is what the Quran says in
chapter 33 verse 49 3349 here we go
Believers you have no right to expect a
waiting
period when you marry believing women
and then divorce them before you have
touched them make provision for them and
release them in an honorable way so do
you say that they do not they don't have
a waiting period unless you have touched
them okay can I read it one more time
yep Believers you have no right to
expect a waiting period when you marry
believing women and then divorce them
before you have touched them yep make
provision for them and release them in
an honorable way so it's saying you
don't need to they don't need to have a
waiting period in between the next
marriage if you have not touched them
yet exactly so how do you know know that
they that these men slept with these
girls who haven't hit puberty yet it's
because they have a waiting period we go
back to the verse it says their period
shall be three months and the same for
those who have not ministr yet their
waiting period is also three months and
because they have a waiting period you
for the ones who haven't minated yet
they haven't a puberty yet it means that
they slept with them that's why they
have a waiting period so
it's saying that it's permissible to
sleep with a woman or I mean it's saying
that it's been if that happens meaning
that's a normal thing it's it's it's
allowed in Islam to sleep with little
girls to marry them sleep with them and
divorce them it's
lawful yeah I don't I don't understand
that I don't understand what is the
point of sleeping with a woman before
they can even get pregnant yep just to
make sure you see that it's not me
that's inter in it this way let me show
you what the scholars say and I there he
breaks this down very well the Ida which
is the waiting period of those in
menopause menopause right those women
who are past the age of ministration and
those who do not have menes meaning they
haven't had their periods yet so he
breaks it down look Allah the exalted
clarifies the waiting period of the
woman in menopause and that is the one
whose ministration has stopped due to
her older age her Ida is three months
instead of the three monthly Cycles for
those who men straight which is based on
chapter 2 ver 228 here's the important
part here it is the same for the young
who have not reached the years of
ministration their Ida is three months
their waiting period is three months
just like those in menopause this is the
meaning of his saying and for those who
have no courses or for those who haven't
administrated yet so it breaks it down
he even quotes like the background
situation of this supporting this view
is what is reported by
ubai
IB that he said oh Allah's messenger
some women were not mentioned in the
Quran the young the old and the pregnant
so Allah the exalted most honored sent
down this Ayah so at first there was a
verse like chapter 2: 228 that told them
what to do in regards to divorcing
certain women but young girls were not
mentioned the older women were not
mentioned and the pregnant women were
not mentioned about when you divorced
them so this verse tells you what what
to do when you divorce the little girl
the older woman and the woman who's
pregnant yeah that's I don't I don't
understand the purpose of sleeping with
a girl who can't get pregnant sick
desires bro that's the purpose the
desires of the flesh lustful men
man-made religion a demonic religion
will teach and give you permission to
sleep with little girls or whatever at
your at your pleasure and Leisure this
is what Islam is
oh my God logic